all right now that was a first chain
rule the reason why I picked that out
before I got to this is because if I
just changed it a little bit in fact you
might even say I might make it a little
simpler making it simpler sort of
actually makes it kind of hard on why
like now that have enough to cause there
what problems does that introduce for us
I don't I don't have the derivative of
the inside function anymore so I like
what does it seem come from right it
certainly doesn't come from this because
if I you know if I go backwards this is
where I end up and you can't just
magically cause I just multiplied by cos
I divided by cos at the same time by the
way why can I do that I can do that with
constants why can't I do it cause
because of math because math says sir is
there a specific reason a specific
mathematical reason why we can't cuz I
seem to do it within the only around
here because it's got a variable in it
it's got a very low and not just any
variable it's the variable I'm
interested in right we saw the same
thing with limits right when the limits
age approaching zero I can actually move
X in and out because it's not the
variable that I'm worried about anyway
that's an aside what can you do what can
we possibly know okay some of you are
like I've seen this before okay let me
just try and back panel for those of you
don't recognize this right remember I
keep saying this over never gonna wonder
how long how sick of this you're getting
I keep saying it's so much of maths I
wonder how much actually so much of
maths is about taking a problem you
don't recognize and that you don't know
how to work on and twisting and turning
into some other form that you do know
how to work with right a lot of Max is
just dedicated to changing problems from
insoluble to solve involve can you tell
anything chemistry anyway so the
question is what could turn this into
out of all of this stuff that could
possibly
be useful to me or how could I do it hmm
are there any good candidates where
would you think first what would it be
easy to turn something of degree 2 into
just something into straight degree 1
can we do that if I told you for
instance you know integrate this right
that's degree 2 you can shift and change
that a lot but you're never going to
turn it to something degree 1
I don't think anyway okay not simply not
in simple terms these guys are out okay
so it's got to be something a little
more complicated what could I use what
what here will be more useful to me than
this now think I sense identities right
now I've heard it a few times the
identity that you want that's most
useful to you is cos 2x now some of you
are like where does that guy come from
why him of all people that seems a bit
random
it's not even silent that matches with
this well the reason why it's cause is
because cause is useful cause it is
useful the double angle formula for
constitutional in a way that the double
angle formula for sine is not what's the
normal standard way of expanding this
cos squared minus sine squared yes
that's the standard way okay but because
these are both Squared's I can turn
either one of these into something else
depending on what's more convenient to
me example I could turn the sine squared
into 1 minus cos squared I could do that
goodnight
double negative that'd give me 2 cos
squared minus 1
just as equally I could change the cos
into a 1 minus sine squared which would
leave me with 1 minus sine squared so
this is kind of handy close to X is
unique in this way sine 2 X doesn't do
it right I can put it in this form or
this form or this one all of which I use
for different kinds of sin
right so which one am I after click
clearly the top one okay now I don't
have 1 minus 2 sine squared X there but
the difference between this and that is
just a few constants right now can uh
can you deal with that
so I write 1 minus 2 sine squared is
constant so how do I make it the subject
I want I'm after this take the 1 over
and then divide by negative 2 which will
do two things number one will stick 1/2
here and number two it'll turn this
around
is that okay let's see if this is
anybody now you can see that even though
in normal terms we would prefer
something like this to this if you've
got a trigger their news question and
they said simplify you got to this right
you'd get fired if you put this is your
answer right but in our case to
integrate this is infinitely better than
this right I can do this this is um I'll
rub that ha I'm gonna stick it out the
front because as a constant doesn't
matter where I quit and then I've got my
1 minus close to X there is that ok what
does it equal that's gonna turn to X
that's gonna turn it to - aha okay it's
just like one of these it just took a
little bit of twisting in turn